[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
harvey weinstein loses his bid to drop
three sex crime charges against him in
los angeles but
gains a partial victory the judge
throwing out one and allowing
prosecutors to amend the count
count five is dead his accuser saying
they're ready for trial
she's ready willing and able to testify
and
a group of black women now suing johnson
johnson accusing the company of
marketing as powder products to them
allegedly knowing the powders could
cause cancer plus he would like a
visceral
is that right mr gerst yes
the emergency hearing in the robert
durst trial the real estate airs
attorneys
asking the judge for a mistrial he's at
risk of sudden death
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
convicted rapist and disgraced movie
producer harvey weinstein
asked a los angeles judge to throw out
three sexual assault charges
long crimes angenet levy is here with
how harvey weinstein won a small victory
yeah brian harvey weinstein's attorneys
had to hope to get three counts
thrown out but that didn't happen only
one of them has been dismissed and the
prosecutor on the case says
even that could be short-lived
harvey weinstein wants the toast of
tinseltown back in a los angeles
courtroom in a jail jumpsuit
asking that three sexual assault charges
filed against him
be thrown out the charge simply is
defective because it's out of statute
los angeles county prosecutors argued
against dismissing the three counts
both sides citing california cases
regarding how much time is allowed for a
charge to be filed
following an offense this case deals
with the multiple victim allegations
in the end the judge dismissed one
charge from an allegation from 2010
but said it could be refiled if the
language was changed
there's simply no factual legal basis
for the charges involving
what the people call jane doe three
which is one of the five victims alleged
in this 11 count indictment which is now
a 10 count indictment
count 5 is dead the prosecution is
prosecuting this case in no small part
by prosecution by volume
rather than by merit meanwhile
weinstein's accusers are ready to
testify
it has not been easy it's been a tough
journey
the long delays are very frustrating as
they are for any victim
attorney dave ring represents one of the
jane does who came forward with a rape
allegation
in 2017. she knows she's going to
testify she's
ready willing and able to testify in the
criminal case
deputy district attorney paul thompson
told the judge that he would refile
that now dismissed charged very soon we
are going to wait and see
when and if that happens brian
thanks angela let's bring in co-host
terry austin to discuss terry
tolling statue of limitations and
refiling can you break that all down for
us
and why this count was dismissed sure
brian every claim has a statute of
limitations
which simply means the amount of time
that you have
to bring a claim those statutes can be
told
meaning they can be paused by certain
actions and
here it was paused because of the filing
of the
indictment so the prosecution filed one
indictment which was
timely filed and then they filed a
second indictment on the same claims and
that wasn't timely filed and what the
judge decided here
is that it can be re-pled this
superseding indictment
can be re-pled with more specificity to
tie
back to the original indictment so she
dismissed this particular
count but she's giving the prosecution
an opportunity to replete
and the prosecution has said that it
will do exactly that so this count isn't
all the way out
yeah but it's interesting to see how the
defense was arguing that there are no
additional facts to add
the facts are as they presented both
indictments being identical let's see
how the prosecution comes back from that
terry what do you think this could mean
for the alleged victims especially jane
doe number three right jane doe
number three was the individual who was
in count
five and as we heard the defense lawyer
saying there
the count is dead but i think that it
obviously must be very difficult to hear
that you may not be able to proceed
against someone
who has allegedly committed sexual
assault as far as you are concerned
knowing
that the other counts might survive but
i think there's hope here
i think that jane doe number three
understands
and i'm sure that the prosecution is
explained
that they have an opportunity here to
replete and to make sure all the
specificity
is there to add whatever additional
facts may be necessary and to also
tie it back to the original indictment
so there's still some hope and i think
that
this particular victim can hold on to
that hope
yeah even if she doesn't testify as a
victim in the case there's a potential
where she can testify as a prior bad act
or uncharged bad act so she still may
get her day in court
and jeanette when will we when will
weinstein be back in court
he'll be back in court on september 13th
for a pre-trial hearing and what was
interesting was the judge
asked harvey weinstein today or during
this hearing
whether or not he would uh want a speedy
trial want that trial to start within
60 days of that september 13th date and
he says he wants it to begin within 60
days
so a lot of us were waiting and watching
to see whether or not
he would waive that time period and say
no they can take longer to prepare or
whether or not he was going to say no i
want this to begin as soon as possible
all right so he wants to exercise his
right to a speedy trial did the judge
make any other rulings
yes harvey weinstein's lawyers like many
lawyers had asked that he be allowed to
wear street clothes during court
appearances the judge
denied that request so as you saw he
appeared in court in a jail jumpsuit
we'll see how that request uh continues
during the trial you know often times
they're allowed to use street clothes
during the trial it's probably just for
these proceedings as we continue thank
you both
turning now to more top legal news a
suspect is under arrest after a shooting
in a movie theater that left one dead
and a well-known tick-tocker on life
support
twenty-year-old joseph jimenez is facing
charges of murder attempted murder and
robbery with a gun
the corona police department says
jimenez shot two people on monday
nineteen-year-old anthony barajas is now
on life support barajas has nearly one
million followers on his tick tock
account
his friend eighteen-year-old riley
goodrich was killed
police say only six tickets were sold
for the movie they were watching
and it appears to be an unprovoked
attack
and in wisconsin the case against a man
charged with kidnapping killing and
dismembering his father
is moving forward sheriff's officials in
dane county wisconsin say chandler
halderson reported his parents as
missing
on july 7th investigators reported
finding bart holderson's torso
with a gunshot wound in a wooded area
law enforcement are still searching for
his mother krista
searching a pond in landfill for
possible remains last week
chandler halderson appeared in court
wednesday waving his right to a
preliminary hearing
the judge bound halderson's case over
for trial
still ahead on law and crime daily will
we see robert durst take the stand in
his own defense at trial
but first why women are standing
together saying a major u.s company
targeted black women for certain
products knowing they could cause cancer
the lawsuit just filed that you need to
know about next
[Music]
welcome back a national group of black
women are suing johnson johnson
claiming the company marketed its baby
powder to black women
knowing the products were not safe
the national council of negro women says
many of its members have developed
ovarian cancer as a result of using the
powder products from johnson johnson
in a lawsuit filed this week the group
alleges that for years
j j marketed and sold these talc-based
products as safe for consumers
and urged their daily use to control
sweat and body odor and protect users
skin
internal documents demonstrate that j
and j target those advertisements to
black women
knowing that black women were more
likely to use the powder products to use
them regularly
these top products were not safe however
johnson and johnson's reportedly facing
thousands of lawsuits
over its talcum products last year a
judge upheld a court order for the
company to pay
two billion dollars in damages to women
who developed ovarian cancer
civil rights attorney ben crump is
representing the ncnw
even in the death of many are black
women who succumb to this ovarian
cancer they are still trying to
marginalize them
and not make them whole it hearkens back
to when black people were counted as
three-fifths of a human being
not as a whole person where johnson and
johnson we declare
with this lawsuit that we are going to
make you acknowledge black women
as whole persons not three-fifths
of a person johnson johnson said in a
statement the accusations being made
against our company are false
and the idea that our company would
purposely and systematically target a
community with bad intentions
is unreasonable and absurd the lawsuit
is being filed in new jersey superior
court
the group did not specify how much in
damages they are seeking
back with us is co-host terry austin and
correspondent angenette leaving
terry what has johnson johnson said in
their defense
and how is a lawsuit showing jay and jay
knew the powder caused cancer well
they're actually
claiming that there were no harmful
products like asbestos or talc
in their products and that those
products did not
cause the cancer and so they are also
saying that they would not intentionally
target a community with any sort of bad
or negative intentions
of course obviously they're marketing to
people and if it looks as though
purchase it they might market there but
they're saying they had no bad
intentions the real question brian
is what did johnson and johnson know and
when did they know it if they knew that
these products were dangerous and they
were targeting
any community then that's a problem
absolutely
engine i don't know about you but
growing up talcum powder was as common
as cocoa butter and vicks in my house so
i'm guessing those ads reach at least
one black woman but how does one prove
that these ads were targeted
you know uh i also grew up with vixx and
johnson and johnson baby powder i think
we actually have some uh
you know in the house here too but um i
think that there will be discovery in
this case of course as there is in every
case and they will also
have a careful review of the marketing
materials
and and what products were marketed to
certain communities we all know that
companies do research they look to see
who they should be marketing to who they
should be
marketing certain products to what
demographics so there may be a lot of
material
available for the crump team to examine
that could support their case
or not obviously i think we all know
about targeted ads and how those works
you open your phone these days and
all of a sudden you were talking with
your friend about one item and your
phone's
advertising into the next moment so
there's plenty of information i think
they can dig into
we'll follow up on this case as it
continues coming up on law and crime
daily shocking new allegations in the
robert durst case
what was said in court that the jury
won't know about ahead
[Music]
we're back a judge is now considering a
mistrial request in the robert durst
case
the millionaire's attorneys are claiming
his failing health will prevent him from
testifying in his own defense
robert durst attorneys say he cannot
physically testify at trial
and if he attempted to do so he risked
further damage to his health
durst is on trial for the december 2000
murder of his best friend susan berman
he signaled multiple times in court that
he plans to take the stand
prosecutors have accused durst of faking
his ailments before the jury was brought
in on thursday
durst doctors testified that the
defendant is at risk of sudden death
and should be hospitalized immediately
there's evidence he may have a tumor in
his parathyroid gland
a parathyroid adenoma he's got the
thyroid i mentioned
he has chronic lung disease both
restrictive
and obstructive he's got significant
cardiac disease that is a imminent
threat to his life at any time
he has esophageal gastric
problems that impair his ability to
absorb nutrients
such that no matter how much you feed
him he will not correct his profound
malnutrition he has kidney disease
he's got a what's called a large
staghorn calculus or kidney stone
that will never pass it cannot it's way
too big
it's by definition infected unlike other
kidney stones
so he's walking around now with an
infection
in his kidney the doctor went on to say
that
transporting durst to court every day
combined with the stress of the trial
all have negative effects on his health
the stresses of coming to court daily
he sits there in a pool of urine
and often feces um he's got i'm sure a
distended bladder
what he needs to have your honor is he
needs to be hospitalized
and he needs to spend
it would probably take two three four
weeks in the hospital
to get accurate diagnosis and treatment
started on his problems
along which he needs to be started on
intravenous nutrition high potency
not just a simple iv then he needs to be
discharged
to a extended care facility
where he can continue to receive the
treatment for at least
about i would i'm just going to guess
three months
and maybe he will get better and
then he could stand trial now let's just
take
let me stop you right there
so bottom line is he too sick to
continue
in trial yes is he too sick to testify
not only is he too sick it's dangerous
and
is he too sick to make the decision
whether to testify or not he's not
capable he's too sick he cannot make
that decision no
on cross prosecutor john lewin asked the
doctor if he's noticed that durst has
gotten better during the trial
including sending nose to his attorney
and the judge
are you aware that back in april mr
durst
wrote a note to the judge because he was
upset
about stipulations that were done and he
accused his attorneys of having
temporary insanity
or collective dementia does that sound
like somebody who doesn't know what's
going on
i i think you're agreeing with me that
he's he's got cognitive defects to write
such a statement
oh my god i think you just made my case
thank you
i'm going to bet no doctor but
when you call your attorneys i think
it's a demented um
and you write a letter to the judge
which i don't think is appropriate
you think that's normal behavior do you
think that's normal cognition
what it shows is that mr durst is
readily engaged
in his assessment of this case
i i have no further questions right
i mean the judgment might be off but the
but the uh
you see the letter i mean it's a it's uh
it is
quite the reasoning is good the logic is
good
uh it's the conclusion's raw but
uh but i think he's thinking right
i mean how can somebody if he's so
impaired
uh pen such a such a beautiful letter
interesting back and forth there when we
come back the judge weighs in
on will robert durst's murder trial for
the death of his best friend continue
find out after the break
back now to the murder trial of robert
durst where attorneys are arguing
whether to proceed
prosecutors say durst's medical
condition should not stop the court from
moving forward
it's a lot of could happen might happen
could affect him might affect him
anybody who's been in this courtroom and
it's amazing to me
that dr klein who's charging
by his own admission fifty thousand
dollars although when you do the math
it's over a hundred thousand
has not bothered to observe the man in
court
uh the court has had the opportunity
this is a person who's not getting worse
he's getting better he is fully engaged
he is
discussing things with his attorney he's
raising objections
he is engaged in this trial and then
finally your honor is the court's aware
what they really want is and i don't i
think the doctor was disingenuous in his
last response
completely disingenuous his comment
regarding
even just his kidney stone is it's never
going to be operable it's never going to
get any better
so the court i think in the court has uh
noticed this previously
what this is is not a request for
mistrial what this really is is a
request for mr dirks
to get a go home get out of jail free
card and never be tried again
and because there is no current acute
situation that requires mr durst to be
hospitalized
we are talking about chronic conditions
which may or may not get better
and again mr durst had very serious
cancer
in 2005. he's still here he will
probably
outlive us all
this defendant is unable
to testify because of his medical
conditions
it's been established and he is losing
his right as a citizen to testify in his
own defense
he'll be in a debilitated state and i
will add the following
unless mr lewin remarkably changes
how he crosses cross-examines
it will certainly be impossible
for mr durst to respond to that kind of
cross-examination
we briefed it we provided you with what
cases we could
we distinguished a villa at least we
tried to
we found other cases that talk about it
we'd ask you your honor to really
seriously consider granting the mistrial
in this instance thank you
thank you i i take the motion seriously
and thus i will take it under submission
i'll be reviewing these uh materials
that have been submitted
robert durst will outlive us all
interesting statement by the prosecutor
and have you ever heard of a person's
health stopping their ability to testify
causing the case to end and what should
the court do
yeah i haven't heard of that ryan i mean
we did a story earlier on in this trial
about
looking at this issue how sick do you
have to be to not move forward
and you know robert durst has said from
the very beginning
that he wanted to take the stand he said
it two or three weeks ago that he was
prepared to take the stand now that's
all changed so
um i don't know if i've ever seen
somebody too sick to take the stand but
i've definitely
not seen somebody too ill to go forward
with a trial so i think that
he they say it's not an acute situation
it just doesn't seem like the judge is
going to grant this motion for a
mistrial and he hasn't done
that in the past either i would agree
here it doesn't seem like the judge is
in the position to actually grant that
terry judge
the judge did handle this hearing a
little different than he did in the rest
of the trial
what did you think of that and should we
be reading into how he's handling both
sides
and kind of calming them down as they
argue well i think today judge windham
did
put his place so to speak once during
the
argument for the mistrial lewin actually
got up to speak
before the defense got up to speak and
it was the defense's motion so the judge
actually had to say
um let the defense speak which
of course lewin sat down and he let de
guerin speak but the other time that i
think
the judge finally did say something to
lewin was
when there was a request by the defense
to
actually instruct the jury that pence
was not doing anything wrong
just because they questioned a witness
and judge lewin actually said look
i'm going to protect the defense just
like i'm going to protect you and i'm
going to instruct the jury that just
because the defense
talked to a witness or tried to get him
to testify i mean they did anything
wrong
so good for the judge absolutely thank
you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you